everyone I'm Lucy I'm Oscar and we've
been playing at some of the brand-new
battle royale mode that's coming to
dying light cold
well it's called brutal royale for the
whole mode itself is called dying light
bad blood not to be confused with the
teats little song
the t-swizzle song demo god no this is a
bible royale mode that's coming stunning
light like as a game that came out a few
years ago now the amount of post-release
support that gamers received from
Techland is kind of incredible and it
still has a very very active and rabid
fan base so like that coupled with while
being a big deal sorry what's battle
royale never heard of it right do you
play most only when it first came out no
I didn't actually play it at all it was
one of those games that I really like to
look on and never ended up actually
finding the time to play so I was
thankful today when we got to play a
little bit of this it's a standalone
Battle Royale kind of like spin off yeah
so instead of you know other games other
battleworld games you have a hundred
players and it's about to become do you
know the last man standing in bad blood
there are only 12 of you but it's pvp
and PVE so you're not only fighting
against other real-life human beings
you're fighting against the zombie
zombies the undead the undead from dying
light so then what you do is there is a
chopper coming to rescue you from this
living hell scape full of zombies but
there's only one spot on that chopper
and of course the guy who is driving the
chopper you know you've got to give him
something so what you do is collect
blood samples from those blood hives
will be seeing like in a second you have
to click the plus sample and when you
click to blood sample you kind of
basically level up and if you get a
certain amount of blood then you are
eligible for that one spot you can win
the golden
to get win the golden taking a longer
life yeah when you collect the blood
correct me if I'm wrong you you get more
health and you get a little bit faster
stronger and so like that I mean it's a
pretty small bump but you know it helps
you on your way to becoming the number
one and if you have like low health you
get your health back as well so it's to
be yes so here this is actually some of
your gameplay you went on like a little
point of the killing spree so not only
are the zombies to contend with you have
the eleven other players and what you're
doing here is brutally murdering them
little parry their little pirate very
well done and then what you can do is
you can take obviously their weapons
their ammo crucially their blood so
there are multiple ways in which you can
actually like level up which means you
don't necessarily have to put yourself
into the thick of things you can just
hunt hunt you mate yeah I really like
that actually and and although you need
to get a certain amount of blood to be
able to call in the chopper that doesn't
necessarily mean you're gonna be the one
that gets on that helicopter right you
can't just hang around the extraction
zone and and kill the other players and
Nick their blood and then it's basically
a dark zone for your my division right
yeah yeah so I put a gameplay whistle
going so you obviously have like
regulars not like their zombie nests
themselves that you have to get the
blood from they can be easy they can be
regular they can be hard this is a hard
guy this is a hard nest
purely because of this guy so I used
molotovs on him I've used a grenade on
him just there I look how little I've
chipped away at him he's ridiculous so
part of the thing that I really liked
about it is again talking about the ways
that you can the multiple ways in which
you can approach things is that you can
actually like run distraction and like
lure them away or wait until another
human being like a human player is like
taking the heat from him and just
basically Nick for blood well in all
watching yeah yeah I I really liked that
kind of like flexibility that it gives
you and I think
the difficulty with what you're placing
him in that last little section there
was that
I mean you presumably at this point had
a pretty basic weapon
I was pretty fresh I'm not gonna lie you
know I I had like a couple of landmines
and I had molotovs I had a grenade
grenade and I completely wasted them all
on him which meant that I was more
willfully unprepared when I actually ran
into more zombies and more humans later
on yeah but of course you can actually
upgrade the weapons you get as well it's
not just a case of picking up new
weapons you can you can actually make
your existing weapons stronger and give
them like weird perks like this is like
a nice upgrade for one of them yeah so
that's what that's the thing I really
loved about OG dying light and you know
Dead Island is that like it was all
about this great melee based combat you
didn't really want to get guns involved
because I would just obviously draw
their zombie to you unless you were into
that I mean no judging like the one you
could do you'll find a weapon and you
notice that when I in my gameplay I'm
pretty much always using this size
because I just had really good feel to
it it was fast break over the side
that's where you give it the size not so
good at climbing like you can you could
take that size and you could keep
repairing it and you could apply mods to
it and just basically make though a
things that you want to like the
crafting so I think that's a really
clever thing that they're doing is that
by taking everything that was so great
about dying light and just like putting
it into this new package yeah and and i
think the most well maybe not the most
attractive thing but something that I
think will definitely help it in the
fight against you know pub G or for ty
and all the rest of these Battle Royale
games is that it is gonna be
free-to-play when it when it eventually
launches yeah so let's talk a little bit
about that so it's going into
essentially like an early access ish
kind of thing yeah it's like early
access on Steam in September yeah that's
gonna be paid so you have to buy a thing
called the founders pack in order to get
that so what that is steam early access
and what they were saying is that once
you've bought the founders pack you'll
get access to exclusive items that will
never be available to other people later
on
can you forget to help I guess you
basically helping to shape and yeah
definitely helping fill the balance
develop the game at that point right and
you get regular updates of course and
then they haven't got a time frame on
the final release yet but that is gonna
be free-to-play it's gonna come to PC
first then Xbox and then here's her yeah
I think sbox has a little exclusivity oh
so those guys I was just fighting there
so not only the zombies and real people
you can get like these these helicopter
drops like you had in there in the main
game like like caches of useful items
weapons and they were a bunch of a I do
too regarding those but then I actually
ran away because some body someone I had
enough blood in order to actually get
the helicopters is born so I didn't
actually open the weapons cache I'm
lucky they did say as well that they're
gonna be bringing more Maps more modes
more weapons that kind of stuff after
launch yeah so like again like what
we've come to expect from tech lines and
dying light is just like tons of support
yeah
again that will help them in in this off
battle royale battle royale yeah exactly
because I think the thing is that pubsey
and fortnight do so well is this or
endless continuous support that they get
and I think if if Techland you know keep
their promises which I'm sure they will
I think this could really rival those
two and and as well we shouldn't mention
that although I think they said that
their current plan is that ranked game
Rhodes will you'll have to enter as a
solo player there are gonna be sort of
casual and private modes as well so this
is actually some of the b-roll the deads
gave us cuz it's like a guy at the end
like actually getting to be one of the
final I actually did manage to get to
the end and I died almost immediately
suceed atomically I advise you know if
it was like me and one other guy and
is that the end is that really the end
this just felt like it's the end for you
it was the end for me but that guy did
have a gun there so there are guns but
like okay no no no man I kept like
dynamite on welcome yeah exactly
I'd say although it did actually and
again like I didn't as much as I like to
look at I'm like I didn't actually get
around to playing it yet but hey if this
is free to play and I can jump on this
and have a quick 10 minute match you
know with a couple of mates in casual a
hundred percent I'll jump on that
so like near Madonna when dying life has
come out like it genuinely was a huge
surprise and I Jenna I loved it and this
again like when I heard batter out right
I was coming to it I was like yeah but
honestly had a whale of a time I think
you'll agree so for more on dying like
bad blood undyne light in general dying
my tubes coming out as well
parkour too much time like in my opinion
not good not make sure you keep your
eyes peeled against
get to the choppa forgot to say that hey
guys whether the whole mode came from